SIERRA: Hey everyone, a quick note before
we start the show. So some of our colleagues
produced this amazing online presentation
about the international refugee crisis,
and it’s been nominated for a Webby this
year. I encourage you to check it out and
if you like what you see, please vote
for us. Voting closes on May 7th. So
go to Vote.WebbyAwards.com and search for
it by its title “No Refugee.” And thanks!
Ah, social media. Love it or hate it, we use
it for almost everything. Staying in touch,
buying things we need, buying things
we don’t need, following the news,
even checking in during a disaster.
But entrusting these platforms with
our information comes at a cost. The
boundaries of our privacy have faded, and
more and more we find ourselves asking,
who’s in charge? Is it legislators?
Is it the platforms themselves? In the
U.S. the answers to those questions are unclear.
But in India, a potentially decisive moment
in digital freedom is going down right now.
India’s ruling party has put forward
new rules that would allow it to trace
and censor private communication. Standing
in its way is WhatsApp, an American-made,
encrypted messaging platform that
is used by hundreds of millions of
Indians. And the outcome could have
ripple effects across the globe.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and
this is Why It Matters. Today,
India’s government versus WhatsApp, and the
looming threat of digital authoritarianism.
GOEL:
India is the world's largest
democracy. If you can imagine,
900 million people voted in the last
national election last year. Out
of a population of 1.3 billion people,
it's just a massive exercised election.
MODY: Yeah, it's huge, it's populous, and
that's what also makes it really fun and
exciting to be on the ground. You certainly feel
the energy, especially in a city like Mumbai.
GOEL: Politicians routinely insult each other on
the campaign trail, criminals of every flavor run
for office and win, so do Bollywood movie
stars, cricket stars. It just never ends.
ARUN: India has always been a fairly
chatty democracy. We talk a lot,
we argue a lot, that's our culture.
SIERRA: Okay so help me understand why WhatsApp is
such a big deal in India? How many
people are actually using it there?
ARUN: Roughly 400 million.
SIERRA: That's a lot of people.
ARUN: It is indeed.
SIERRA: This is Chinmayi Arun, she is
a resident fellow at Yale University,
and the founder of a research center at
National Law University in Delhi. She’s also
a leading legal expert on the intersection
between freedom of speech and technology.
SIERRA: And so why WhatsApp? Why not,
you know, Instagram, or Snapchat?
ARUN: The elite platforms are used by everyone,
but WhatsApp is the one that really appeals to
people. If you have a phone that's not too fancy,
if you don't speak English, you don't read, or you
don't have access to an expensive data connection,
you can still use WhatsApp. So it started with,
"Hey, you don't have to spend one rupee or two
rupees per text, you just save them up and then
they send whenever you're in Wi-Fi." And so a lot
of people with not a lot of money, which is many,
many Indians, decided that this works for them.
And then WhatsApp had these multimedia features
which people started using and started liking.
And I have mixed feelings about this because
the good thing is that I get to talk to my
grandma, and she finally has forgiven me for
moving across the Atlantic, she can look at my
home and say things about my plants or whatever.
SIERRA: Of course.
ARUN: But if you're sitting in an Indian
airport and watching the number of people
who do video calls, they sort of subject
you to their conversations. Mixed feelings.
GOEL: WhatsApp is really a messaging platform,
and that can be one-to-one messages like me
sending a message to you, but it's also
very commonly used in India for groups.
I am Vindu Goel, and I am a technology reporter
for The New York Times based in Mumbai, India.
SIERRA: Vindu also covers
Indian economics and culture,
and has written extensively about
free speech and misinformation under
India’s ruling party. We called him
at his home in Mumbai on WhatsApp.
GOEL: WhatsApp has become so embedded in
life in India that people use it in their
business transactions, so you can order
groceries from your corner grocery store
over WhatsApp. I buy an airline ticket from
MakeMyTrip, which is one of the big online
travel agencies. They send me a confirmation
message on WhatsApp with my E-ticket details.
SIERRA: For those of us based outside of India,
handling a basic transaction may require a
few different platforms. You find out about a
concert on Instagram, RSVP for it on Facebook,
maybe share the notification on Twitter, buy
your ticket on Ticketmaster, and receive the
confirmation on Gmail. But for Indians, WhatsApp
is often the one-stop-shop for everything.
In other words, an application
from Silicon Valley has become
basic infrastructure for the second-most
populous nation on Earth. That’s a pretty
big deal, and it helps illuminate why the
government is pushing for greater control.
GOEL: WhatsApp was founded in 2009 by two former
employees of Yahoo, it’s an American company,
it was founded in Silicon Valley, and they
basically built a very simple messaging
service. It became very popular, and it
caught the attention of Mark Zuckerberg,
the chief executive and founder of Facebook.
Zuckerberg decided in 2014 to buy WhatsApp
and pay the still astonishing price of
$22 billion for this messaging company.
SIERRA: Yikes. That's a lot.
GOEL: It's a lot.
LA Times: Facebook is making
a mobile push with its deal
to buy real-time messaging service, WhatsApp.
CNN: It's still an incredible price to pay
for a company that’s just a few years old.
ABC News: It also makes tiny WhatsApp
more valuable than some of the most
established companies in the country, including
American Airlines, Marriott Hotels, and Xerox.
MODY: And it came at a crucial moment for
Facebook when it really was trying to find
ways to diversify its revenue base, and
also get in touch with more mobile users.
I'm Seema Mody, global markets correspondent
with CNBC Business News. And suddenly came
this messaging platform that was not only gaining
prominence here in the U.S., but around the world.
In fact, I believe that the average daily user
rate on WhatsApp was much higher than Facebook
Messenger. Facebook saw that and said, “this
is such a strategic bet for us, let's acquire
it and find a way to really incorporate
it into our user base and our platform.”
SIERRA: But WhatsApp is free, right?
MODY: WhatsApp is free and I think
this is still a developing story
to see how Facebook is really trying to
incorporate WhatsApp into its business,
and will you one day see ads on WhatsApp?
That's certainly been one of the big questions.
GOEL: Zuckerberg was prescient in that this
technology of a very simple messaging app
was going to become very popular. Today, WhatsApp
has more than two billion users around the world.
It is by far the most popular messaging app in the
world, and one of its biggest claims to fame is it
emphasizes privacy. All messages on the service
use something called end-to-end encryption.
SIERRA: Okay so, in most cases when you send an
email, or a text message, it gets encrypted. That
means that the information inside is locked up in
a code, so that outsiders can’t read it. However,
the service providers that pass your message along
can read it - whether that’s Apple, or Gmail,
or Facebook, whoever. They all have the keys to
that code. And that makes your message vulnerable.
Enter end-to-end encryption. With this
technology, none of the middlemen have
the keys. Only you and the person you
are sending it to can break the code.
GOEL: WhatsApp can't read it, even if the
government came knocking at the door of WhatsApp,
WhatsApp would have nothing really to give
them, and so your information is private.
SIERRA: And that makes it unique to other
services, messaging services, like, whether you're
sending a text message, or even Facebook Messenger
where that information does live somewhere.
GOEL: Yeah. Most other messaging services
in the world are not end-to-end encrypted,
and certainly none of the really popular
ones. But WhatsApp has made it really easy,
you don't have to think about
encryption. It just is encrypted.
SIERRA: Because so much of India’s
communication happens on WhatsApp,
end-to-end encryption has made it
very difficult for the government
to investigate messages, in
the name of national security.
ARUN: People are not making phone calls anymore.
They're not even walking over to their neighbor
and saying things, they're just texting them. And
where there is speech, there is harmful speech.
SIERRA: It’s not news that social media can
bring out the worst in people. The platforms
we use every day are teeming with sexism,
racism, misinformation, and violent ideologies.
It’s the same in India, where social media has
amplified problems that are a
lot older than the Internet.
PBS NewsHour: Rumors and lies spread
like wildfire across the internet,
including across chat applications like WhatsApp.
Al Jazeera: There are many first
time users in India who think that
whatever comes in their WhatsApp inbox, is true.
ARUN: The one that's really made the headlines
is that there was a lot of vicious hate speech
circulating on WhatsApp. So for example, the
Muslim community is under quite a lot of pressure
in India right now and it's really sad. One of
the ways in which they're discriminated against
is that some upper-caste Hindus, don't eat beef.
And so the rumor circulating on WhatsApp will say
things like, "X has beef in his fridge." Or, "Y
is his transporting a cow carcass." And since
it's already been sold to people as a threat to
their religion, when a rumor like that reaches
people that already feel threatened, and feel
like these people are out to get all the Hindus,
and they're trying to destroy our religion
by eating beef, and lynch mobs attack them.
SIERRA: Wow.
ARUN: And they're popularly
called the WhatsApp lynchings.
GOEL: In early 2018, there was a wave of false
messages on WhatsApp about child kidnappers
prowling various parts of India trying to steal
people's children, and this panicked a lot of
people and mobs attacked strangers in various
parts of India and killed them. Beat them to
death, tied them up, hung them, all kinds
of terrible things. More than 20 people died
in just a span of a few months because of these
rumors. And after these rumors started appearing,
the central government, went after WhatsApp and
said, "You need to find a way to trace these
messages and stop these messages." And this set
up a feud with WhatsApp that has still not been
resolved. The government says it doesn't want
to read your messages, the government says they
don't want to spy on the content of messages.
They're not asking WhatsApp to break the
encryption of messages and just show them what's
in the messages, but what they are saying is,
"You need to be able to trace back the pathway of
a message, and you have to find a way to do that,
because if some message goes viral, we want
to find out who sent it." And we'll see what
happens. I mean, WhatsApp has said that to do
that would require significant changes to their
service and they haven't said whether they'd be
willing to make such changes to their service.
SIERRA: And that brings us back to
the rule changes that the Indian
government is proposing. The
draft hasn’t been finalized,
but the current language would require platforms
such as Facebook, Instagram, WhatsApp, TikTok,
and others to remove unlawful posts, and trace
their origins within 72 hours of a request.
This sounds pretty reasonable. If misinformation
on a private social media platform
is leading to real-life violence,
the need to have an authority step in and
offer regulation seems like a rational impulse.
Still, context matters, and before
we go any further, it’s probably a
good idea to learn a bit more about India’s
ruling party, popularly known as the BJP,
which some critics have described as
authoritarian and ethno-nationalist.
SIERRA: Can you tell me a little bit
just about the ruling party in India,
and how they interact with social media?
ARUN: So, the ruling party in India was known
for their use of social media, modeled on the
Obama campaign, by the way. And so there's a part
of it in which they've been much lauded for taking
to the social media and sort of modernizing
Indian politics that way. It's also known for
a huge rise in the number of Internet shutdowns.
So it's interesting because they take pride in
being accessible to people on social media, but
at the same time, are quite controlling of it.
SIERRA: It sounds like they
know how powerful it is.
ARUN: Yes, it does.
SIERRA: So, what do you mean by Internet
shutdowns? Like, they're just completely
shutting down access to everybody in a
certain place for a certain amount of time?
ARUN: Yes, what I mean by an Internet shutdown
is, a shutdown of all Internet services,
but typically also telephone services, so
basically it's a full communications shutdown.
SIERRA: That's crazy, and scary. And how
do people react to something like that?
ARUN: Fury, mostly. My colleagues and
I have been tracking this from when
it started in Kashmir years ago.
For the Kashmiris, it's terrible,
because they're stuck completely cut off from
the rest of India and from the rest of the world.
SIERRA: The story of Kashmir could take up an
episode on its own. We don’t want to oversimplify,
so check our show notes for the full story.
Kashmir is a Muslim-majority region between
India and Pakistan that the two nuclear
states have been fighting over since
1947. Tensions have led to war four times
already. In order to tamp down dissent,
the BJP shut down the Internet in Kashmir for
more than 200 days. This is just one example
of how far they’re willing to go in order
to control the flow of information online.
GOEL: The BJP is very good at winning
elections, and one of the skills that
it’s really mastered is how to use social media to
disseminate misinformation. They have factories,
people who are essentially creating content
to put out every day. Some of it's true,
some of it's false, some of it's half
true. There's a certain irony about a
BJP-led government seeking help from WhatsApp
to crack down on misinformation when, in fact,
the very same government is the source of much
of the misinformation that moves on WhatsApp.
SIERRA: So, you don't buy the
argument that the only reason
the government wants traceability is
to stamp out dangerous disinformation?
GOEL: No. The Indian government has used
surveillance against dissidents in Kashmir.
People widely believe that cell phones
are tapped, that SMS messages are being
read by the government. There's a huge sort of
black budget for various kinds of surveillance
operations that the government does, and
they do it in the name of national security,
they say they're finding terrorists, much like
the United States government that does a lot of
surveillance in the name of national security. And
the laws are quite broad in India. It essentially
gives the government the right to do surveillance
for pretty much any reason it pleases,
and so no one really trusts that it would
only be used for good and noble purposes.
SIERRA: Watchdogs in India have been
concerned about the constitutional right
to privacy for a long time. Some critics
see the latest push by the BJP as part of
a larger consolidation of power and a shift
towards a Hindu nationalist agenda. They’re
concerned that new surveillance tools
will be used in discriminatory ways.
GOEL: The request that WhatsApp provide a
way to trace messages as part of a broader
set of rules that the Indian government
wants to impose on internet companies,
these rules would also require companies to more
closely monitor for certain kinds of content,
would give the government power to require the
removal of content that it considered threatening
to the state or public order, a variety of rather
open-ended justifications. And so the risk,
the concern that a lot of people have is that
essentially this will give the government the
power to censor anything at once and
force the internet companies to comply.
SIERRA: So, in response, has WhatsApp
done any other things? Have they made
other moves to sort of placate
this request and say, look,
we're taking care of this misinformation
that is truly leading to people dying?
GOEL: Yes. So, one step they took
was to limit the number of people
or groups you could forward a message to, to five.
People would get some exciting message or people
would get some threatening message and say,
"I need to let everybody I know, know about this,"
without really thinking about whether it's true or
not, or knowing, and then all of a sudden this
forward shows up and you don't really know where
it came from, and it goes viral. And so the idea
was to slow the speed, slow the dissemination. And
they tested that in India and they found it worked
so well that they've now rolled it out globally.
SIERRA: In fact, since we interviewed Vindu,
WhatsApp has made further restrictions. When
a user receives a message that has
already been forwarded five times,
they can now only send it to a single
person or group. The changes are aimed
at stemming the flow of viral
misinformation about COVID-19.
SIERRA: I mean, it sounds like WhatsApp is making
efforts to address these issues just without
breaking encryption. That seems to be the main
thing that they're refusing to do at this point.
ARUN: So far. I believe that they're
now under pressure to break encryption
also. And that's why I said they're in a
hard place, because if it comes to that,
if it comes to either leave the country
or break encryption, the question is,
are they going to give up all the big money, the
big market, or are they going to break encryption?
SIERRA: So, what will happen if WhatsApp refuses?
ARUN: So I think if you asked WhatsApp
the answer to this question, they'll say,
"Well, another player will move in." I don't
think that it'll be as easy or as smooth,
because WhatsApp offers functionality that not all
platforms do. And the second thing we don't know,
because WhatsApp has never tried it, is
that how far will the public be okay with
this? So if you tell the Indian public that,
basically, the Indian government said enable
surveillance or leave, and therefore none of
you have WhatsApp anymore in this enormous
country with fairly rebellious people. It
would be interesting to see how that lands.
SIERRA: So, what is at stake for
Indians as this all plays out?
ARUN: One is that it kills all the wonderful
things that the Internet brought to India.
All the young women that learned to rebel quietly.
The organizing, people who learned because they
were a part of WhatsApp groups that helped educate
them, as I told you in the beginning, human
communication moved to WhatsApp. And the thing
is that India has always been a fairly chatty
democracy. We talk a lot, we argue a lot, that's
our culture. Amartya Sen's written about it,
and he said, "We didn't need free speech to create
public discourse in India. It was always a thing.
We were always arguing and talking." And we've
never had a state that's been able to monitor that
end-to-end. Now that our communication's moved
online, and one private company holds it all,
if that private company chooses to share
that communication with the government
for the first time possibly in Indian
history, the Indian government will be
able to conduct mass surveillance in India.
And so the question is, what will that do to
both the Indian formal democracy, but
also the democratic spirit of India.
GOEL: If there is censorship on a wide scale
you're really going to see a weakening,
perhaps crushing over time, of that democratic
spirit. India will move more in the direction
of China where the government decides
which information gets out there,
and every once in a while somebody finds a
way around the censors and posts information
that the government doesn't want them to post.
That's the risk with India, is the government
becomes the source of information and you lose
some of these other sources of information.
SIERRA: As a reminder, there are 1.3 billion
people living in Indians. 1.3 billion people
whose freedoms could be eroded. And the decision
that goes down in India won’t just stay there. It
could shape the digital freedoms of people
all across the world in the years to come.
GOEL: So, the precedent that this would set, if
WhatsApp added traceability, is India would not
be the only country to ask. Other countries would
ask. Once it's there, anybody can ask for it.
ARUN: It could be the beginning of a
movement. And so, Pakistan has introduced
a new draconian law recently that appears
to be modeled on the Indian one. In fact,
my Pakistani friends and I joke that our countries
sometimes borrow the worst ideas from each other.
So there's that. There's Kenya, that used
India's digital ID system, and may feel
like they can do this too, with WhatsApp. I
believe that Israel and Brazil have also had
what they might term as “WhatsApp problems.”
And so, you might have a copycat situation,
of many countries' authoritarian rulers feeling
that, "Well, if WhatsApp gives way here,
it will give way in my country too." So that's
the digital rights problem, that it could spread,
and you end up with authoritarian countries around
the world, and that's dangerous for everyone.
SIERRA: It’s still unclear how and when the new
rules will be implemented, but the twist is that
a big part of the outcome rests in the hands of
a private American company. WhatsApp could comply
with the request, they could attempt to negotiate
and compromise, or they could just refuse,
and see whether the Indian government
would truly push them out of the country.
MODY: I think when you're that big, you do inherit
some level of responsibility to set the standard
and ensure you're not just trying to monetize a
country's populous nation, and instead are coming
in to try to really work with the country,
to do the right thing. I think as a company,
you could argue, if they come into a foreign
country, they should be trying to do more good
than bad. And it's interesting, if you look at the
CEOs of some of the most powerful tech companies
in the last two years, the number of trips
individuals like Mark Zuckerberg, Tim Cook,
Jeff Bezos have taken to India to spend time
with Prime Minister Modi and really try to build
up their personal relationship with the Indian
leader, I think it just speaks to how much they
see India as such a big opportunity, but also to
the big challenges they're facing on the ground.
SIERRA: But the ultimate
draw is just the market size?
MODY: I think that's exactly what it is. 1.3
billion people, half of which are under the
age of 25. These companies see this as
a huge opportunity, especially at a time
when China's economy is slowing down, you
look at India as that next big bet in Asia.
GOEL: I think that all of these companies have
become very powerful. We use their services,
we trust lots of information to them.
Sometimes they treat it with great respect,
sometimes they abuse that trust, and people are
distrustful of the tech companies as much as
they're also distrustful of the government. Tech
firms need to figure out how to address some of
these very real concerns raised by governments
without fundamentally altering the nature
of the product. I'm not sure it's possible. The
attitude in Silicon Valley for a long time was,
"We're not going to help. We don't want
to help." Twitter quite famously called
itself the free speech wing of the free speech
party. They don't say that very much anymore,
because it's complicated, right? So, Twitter
became this cesspool of trolls and attacks and
all kinds of nasty stuff, and they were losing
users and they had a bad reputation among a lot
of people and they realized that they have to
figure out how to draw lines. But where do you
draw the lines? There's no easy solutions. This
technology has in many ways gone out of control,
no one can really control it, even the companies
themselves have trouble controlling how it's used.
SIERRA: Right. I mean in an ideal
world if every government was just
perfect and amazing and benevolent, of
course they should be a part of this,
and of course they should be helping
monitor something that is so out of control,
but you can't trust that everybody has the
best interests at heart and wouldn't take
advantage of a situation. And it sounds like
there's just no easy answers for these things.
GOEL: No. I mean, these are democracies,
right? Autocracies are even worse,
but even in a democracy, even in a democracy
like India, a democracy like the United States,
there's always an opposition, and whoever's in
power is going to be tempted to use these tools
to hurt the opposition. It's just the nature
of politics and the nature of temptation.
SIERRA: Our freedoms are increasingly
expressed and exercised online. And
by concentrating our freedom of speech online,
we have also made it more susceptible than
ever before to surveillance and censorship.
Nobody knows the right way to deal with this,
and the argument is being hashed out,
in different ways, all over the world.
Soon we’ll hear what the world’s
biggest democracy has to say.
As we mentioned throughout the episode, there is
a whole lot more to learn about India, WhatsApp,
and everything else that plays into this complex
topic. So visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters and take a
look at the show notes, we added a bunch of
really great stuff to take a deeper look.
Interested in saying hi to the Why It Matters
team? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Be sure to subscribe to the show on
Apple Podcasts, Spotify, Stitcher,
or wherever you get your audio. And if
you like the show, leave us a review!
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations. The show is created and
produced by Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me,
Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer is Markus
Zakaria and our assistant producer is Rafaela
Siewert. Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor,
and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass,
Jeff Reinke, and Alyssa Ayres.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle
Sierra signing off. See you next time!